I think it was just turn your phone's
off
and reveal the game and my name is
Vasily and I am presenter so there is no
useful information I think we can start
and you'll not be worried about present
me and talk everyone to silence their
phones and so on
ok hello everybody my name is Vasily
I'm developer stalked by develop in
Yandex I am the main developer of GPU
version of this library and today I will
talk about what is can boost what
problems it could solve and give you a
tutorial this library was developed in
Yandex for everyone who doesn't know
Yandex is a Russian IT company
it's a biggest search engine in Russia
it's bigger than Google in Russia no not
in and we've been using greedy and
boosting for many many years to solve
our production tasks I think the first
reaction of our internal library to use
the library was developed in 20 and 7
when there was no exhibitor and we've
already assault problems on very big
dataset with our internal life region
most recently library and in Taylor
summer we've released in open source our
latest version of deal with the library
this library is can boast before we will
go to the total I want to briefly
discuss what can boost is what is
Gandhian boost incur and what problems
you could solve is gradient boosting
because it's a tutorial for everyone and
firstly I wanted to ask a question how
many of you knows about Radian boosting
please turn your hands up ok ok good and
the second question how many of you
heard about campus before this tutorial
ok this is also good so there will be
use you suppose ing information for
everyone I think ok so what is guidepost
caboose is a machine and criteria that
is designed to solve supervised doing
tasks
we have several different type of skies
clearing problems which mean interest
off and they could be specified by type
of inputs that we needs to do this for
example inputs could be images for
images we need to use evaluation neural
networks they provide you very good
results and it's the state of the art
technique god boost is not a neural
network it's a vibrator that works with
structured data and for structured data
we have structured it is a very
classical type of inputs we have the
matrix there are also matrix columns in
matrix each column is a feature or a
predictor and each row is a some
observation for each observation we have
label and we need to predict this label
based on a description of observation by
based on a reactor of features and for
such type of inputs we have very good
technique it's called with ein Bustan
and it's usually it's realistic on
decision trees that provides you a
state-of-the-art results
this technique builds in stable or
decision trees and symbol is a linear
combination we have several different
risk we we apply them and we have some
projection this technique builds this in
stable and greedy manner and this
ansible will give you very good results
on structured data usually this result
will the best that you can achieve on
this data set this technique is not very
powerful it could be used not only all
very big data sets it could be used on
small data and because of this which has
very big number of applications you
could find applications of boosting in
research in industry and today it's very
well known because of repetitions on
Cagle
almost any competition where we have
structured data will use within some
Witten fiber in as part of in solution
and here on the slide you can see some
examples where you can apply gradient
boosting and don't think that it's every
everywhere area this all examples that
could be used you
used it almost everywhere whenever you
need machine yank and supervise
tailoring you could try you almost
always could try to use booting in some
way for example you should not think
that neural networks and deal with our
competitors these techniques are not
computer to set all they could be
efficiently combined together the end
boosting works the structured data a
neural networks will work with a
structured data like images and lets me
give one example assume we need to
predict if the person is ill for this we
could go in a classical way we could
measure temperature of person mr. blood
trail ask him some questions and and
make some other predictors based on our
problem domain knowledge create a vector
gather historical data and train model
it could start with simple linear model
then we could train ready and boost
decision tree model and use this model
to predict illness of person in the
future or we could have some hardware
like x-ray that produced us some raw
data like image or some other signal and
we could train a neural network and
solve the same task Oh what what is
better we could combine the raw data and
use nearly no to your control vector and
easy and boosting in one model and this
will give you benefits it's very simple
we just train your neural network on
with some images for example then we
have a vector with probabilities the
predictions of neuron Turkish
probability this probability that a
person is ill check this probability
edit to a matrix that will be used in
gradient boosting decision place and
that's all we could train model on as I
said with just classical structured data
and predictions of neural network and
this usually provides very good results
so to work with billion we think we need
just one thing we need to ensure that
columns in our matrix are of our
numerical ones ingredientes tank
when we got the decision three could
only use numerical features its
classical type of features we could
compare with two values of two valence
and say if one is less or other is
bigger or otherwise and indecision
trivial then we will then use which
value we will select our squad and split
the data based on some condition so such
features are natively supported in a
decision trees but in real world data we
have for one more important type of
inputs its categorical pictures and for
example in pandas data sets part of the
data frames so we very often will use
some columns which are not know miracle
once much categorical like text or
string or and so on and we working with
such predictors is pretty hard task it's
not very easy to use them in decision
trees there is one technique that almost
everyone knows it's one portrait
audience this technique provides good
results but only for categorical
features with small number of distinct
values for example here on the slide we
have a categorical feature occupation
and there is just five G five different
values but in real-world data we have
categorical features like hash tags
example they have millions of different
values and welcome to such predators in
decision trees is hard we can't train
model constrain a good decision tree
model good and stable of decision tree
to work is such bigger number of
distinct values they exist several
techniques that allow us to work with
categorical features with high
cardinality and in conversed with
information to them so composed could
work not only with categorical features
a small number of values but is for
categorical fishes a Skycar technology
and and you don't need to do anything
you just need to to search in your input
matrix a column right in the in column
with input column
some text instead of flawed number and
everything will work but I will talk
about this later
so caboose is a library that could work
with categorical features
it's our advantage and our techniques
allows caboose to achieve is a state of
the art results or publicly available
data sets here you can see a table you
compared our library with our
competitors its ally GBM extremists and
asked or we've reviews publicly
available and said and tuned key
parameters of each library skipper opt
and results here on a slide sometimes
can boost is significantly better like
on Amazon data set sometimes it's just
slightly better but nevertheless and
booster will give you a very good
results here we've compared so there is
no closer this is objective that each
library optimize so if you have that set
with categorical features then it's
definitely a good idea to try cal post
okay when we deal with boosting
libraries everyone wants not only
quality but that library works fast and
sometimes people think that car boost is
not very fast library because we have
and special techniques that works with
categorical features this technique is
computationally pretty expensive and all
our competitors does not have these
techniques these techniques and really
someone trains model on service
categorical features and boost could be
slower than other libraries because
other libraries just don't do anything
to deal with categorical features and so
he probably will not have a very good
quality like you see on previous table
but when someone needs to work with just
numerical features or with numerical
features and one hot encoding features
what encoded features then performance
will be
very good firstly our CPU version will
be comparable in speed to the other
libraries he to prove this we've
measured time that we need to be on 100
decision trees with similar complexity
on three data sets that has said you can
see on a slide it's just with numerical
features and as you can see sometimes
can both days faster like on Epson said
sometimes it's slower like on Hicks or
cover type but car booster still works
still not significantly slower oil then
competitors and could be used to train
models but this cpu Gorshin when we need
to deal with very big that says it's
very bad idea to use CPU and exam and
these set examples not examples of big
data this that are small and even for
them it's not very a good idea to use
CPU you will need to you'll need several
hours or even several days to do grid
search or some hiepro parameter
optimization to train models on these
data sets today we have GPUs GPUs are
fast and this is again boosted condition
tree could be efficiently accelerated on
GPU for example here on a slide you can
see a chart this is relative speed ups
of several different GPUs compared to
CPU for great for our library we have TP
version and this VP version
significantly faster than our superiors
here we've used 56 logical course
CPU it's very powerful CPU its duo
socket and you will not find such CPUs
in desktops for example user and we've
used several modern GPUs even old
generation GPU is four times faster than
CPU on axis there is a number of samples
in the set and we've fixed number of
features so we have the sets we decide
we have numerical data set
dense numerical sets with
800 features and different number of
samples the more samples you have the
first de PUE the big difference between
GPU and CPU will be and if you have
approximately 4 million samples then GPU
will show all show the best results it
will be almost fortune 40 times faster
than our CPU right there most powerful
NVIDIA GPU one important thinker here
have used Tesla GPUs it's very expensive
GPU but we could buy nvidia Titan B that
will provide you similar to be 100
speed-up it will be almost 40 times
faster but it will cost you the same
amount of money that this Intel Xeon CPU
and the difference is very big so we
have very good GPU version but it's not
only faster than our CP version this
version is faster than our competitors
he almost like the same that I said that
I've showed you before but now we
compared our GPU version with reversions
of our competitors and a picture says
for itself you know faster and we
sometimes search 20 to 40 times faster
than competitors and one what you think
this does that again a small our DP
version could work not only on one GPU
we could work on several GPUs and for
this you'll see even better results and
I think a large iam can't even work with
two or more GPUs and my experience with
the booth says that it's not very well
on GPU for big deficits but it's only my
ok now the last thing that should be
noted and when we speak about
performance we usually speak about
training time but the training time
matches when we solve some kind of
computation and all do some analysis
when we need salt reduction task we want
to not only at or learn fast
we need to predict fast
because the young model then we will
ship it to production and we will need
to answer the creators for users and
very often it's time critical service
and our a special type of decision trees
this decision and because of this we
could apply our model very fast here on
a slide we've compared the prediction
time for our library and our competitors
and me to ng 2 or 40 times faster so
it's very big difference and what this
gives us it's I think 4000 Chris we've
applied it to Epson data set of is 1/2
million samples I think and I think
there was just six trees sounds like
this much I don't remember the exact
numbers because a big part was made by
my colleague but it's just examples we
will have we will be significantly
faster because you see three hard top
like and we are using special type of
decision trees that very easy to apply
and other libraries can't be as fast as
can be so fast because just because of
the design decisions okay and one more
thing about this slide the first three
columns are time we need to apply in one
thread and the second three columns are
timing in to apply in such as to threats
okay what so this performance gives us
already great benefits in boost incur
because one nice property you could
gather more data and if we have more
data we will train better model also we
could increase in sample size and this
also give us benefits if you could learn
dust two times faster then you could
take two times more data and in
real-world production scenario you will
train or in the same time by to model
again if you could apply the bigger
model in a special time restriction
then you could this also will give you
very great benefits in with conversely
you could tray and very big models
because we could learn the past and we
could apply them fast and this proves
provides you benefits and quality if you
have not if you sold in clear production
tasks and you could gather more and more
data and your restrictions are hardware
and not letter said that provided to you
by some repetition for example on Kegel
okay so a brief summary of I've talked
about what I think I talked about today
we will talk about GN boost decision
tree library it's kinda bust which works
with numerically just like any boosting
library but we also could work with
categorical features he provides
state-of-the-art quality for categorical
features our library has is very
efficient we have very good security we
we have state the purchased GP version
today of openly available boosting
fibrous today and we could apply models
very fast and finally our library is
easy to use and has good visualization
package and this I will show you in the
second part of our talk in tutorial so
for the tutorial we need to do you will
need to download ipython notebook it
there is a link there is risk your quad
you could just scan it and get the link
and you will also need to install
dependencies that are here on a slide I
think you give you two or three minutes
so you could download everything
install and we will switch to the next
part our talk and maybe this will it
will be a good idea if you just photo
this so we could it will go faster then
everything okay
and while everyone starts I could ask
some questions so we will not spend time
okay are you ready
could you continue okay so now I will
switch to a pattern and we'll show you
how to use CAD Boston so one moment I
will make me a Miller your display gene
okay so today we will know how to use I
can boost boost this has a Python
package and so today it's a PI data but
just for your information we could also
work from command line and we have an
package for our watch today we will be
fighting and today's we have tutorial
based on Amazon employee access
Challenger this is the data set is a
categorical features and we need to
solve classification problem so today's
tutorial will be only about
classification but if you will need to
solve a regression task or or going to
rank then can boost also would do this
if if you want I could make it slightly
bigger I think
good okay so interstellar dust
dependencies maybe or on a slide if
something does not work you should check
that every package is installed
and check please let your version of
caboose tea is the most recent one some
parts of tutorial could no entry on old
versions of CAD was like 0.9 or 0.8 okay
so when we saw subscribers giving tasks
the first I think that we need to do is
to load data set in the memory and and
maybe we process it some speed decides
to matrix with speeches and we and
reactor of his labels and so on today
you don't need to download anything by
hand we provide the set which will be we
will use could be download automatically
it is a helper function from our package
so in a chemist we have packaged
datasets and in this package we have the
said Amazon just like in current cell we
could download data frame could download
Amazon learning set and tested in pandas
dataframes so I just do it
donut and here I have two data frames
each data frame is a Amazon etc has
eight nine categorical features and
label reactor first column not set is a
action that we need to predict it's 0 or
1 and the next nine combs are our
features which will be used in our
machine model in this table categorical
features are just numbers
why because Amazon doesn't want to
provide us the real data and this was
obtained by a some hash function when we
will use to solve your production tasks
or some competitions we could also
provide just strings and not and you
don't need to make it numbers okay
so firstly let splitter out the set to
reacted with that beam inch to predict
and to matrix these features okay when
we will needs to deal with most you will
need to always do the one important
thing you will need to decide what
columns are categorical ones and what
columns are numerical ones and store
somewhere this information because can
boost can't automatically decide for you
if column in input matrix is categorical
or the if this column is numerical one
so today we set as only categorical
features so I've created list is Cola in
which all features marked as categorical
we have nine features and so this is
seconds of from zero to eight does
before we will start some length let's
look at number of zeros and ones in our
target reactor in our labels so we know
how many zero costs and ones because for
education tasks it matters when we solve
problems on imbalance just as it's it's
hard anyone have balanced data and today
our set is imbalanced we will we have
just approximately two thousand of zeros
and almost 31,000 of ones to work risk
and mostly you need to create a special
wrapper class that we will provide can
boost access from or access to edit in
our optimized for in our optimized way
all they just should be encompassed we
have class this class stores the data in
format that you can could deal with
because he wants to learn occasionally
we could create our wrapper class that
will be used to store the data in
several different ways
firstly you could create dust from
bundles data frame
for this we need to provide an argument
data with the matrix these features or
it could be numpy array
numpy matrix which could be a punch data
frame secondly we need to provide a
reactor with labels and finally we need
to provide argument cutting cut features
this is a list with indices of
categorical columns in our matrix and
just like this we could create that our
internal letter said that will be used
in yoga the set could be created
explicitly like I did this here or when
we need to train our model it could be
done implicit here I will show about it
was this but it's not very efficient
when we pass the data like this we will
need to copy everything from pandas
dataframe to our internal format and if
you if your data is very big if you have
the set for example for 100 gigabytes
you you will need to copy everything and
you could run out of memory so ok bus
provides you a way to download to load
the data in memory automatically from a
disk what's more you will do it
efficiently if you need to download if
you need to load data in memory with the
pandas for example then that said that
very big data set will be downloaded to
very slow I tried 500 550 100 gigabyte
the setter and it took me I think 2 or 3
hours to download it in the memory and
can boost will do the significant faster
in several minutes ok so let me show how
to download the set in memory fro from
Wizkid Boston firstly we need to save it
so we have a file from which we can load
everything so in the cell this cell I
will say
our data set in two formats firstly it
will be touched by rigid format and
secondly it will be a comma-separated
format and now I have on a disc to the
assets yeah in the next two tells I
looked at them printed first two lines
and conversed good
automatically at all the data from was
files the only thing that he will need
to do is to create a description of
columns I said before and I will say
that again I think in that we need
always specify in this is all
categorical columns and two and for
users feyten users we provide to you a
special function a function that could
create a description of columns for card
was when we load the data from a disk we
need to provide a file columns column
description file which will describe you
type of each colony in you under the set
oh it's good or if I want to be more
precise it's this file should describe
only fitting vertical columns and index
of a label column all other columns I
seem to be numerical ones by default so
to to Python users to provide in-car
boost to chills special function create
CD function that could create these
files automatically from a code this
function needs to three arguments
firstly it needs the most simple usage
of this function firstly we need to
provide index of level column secondly
we need to provide in this of
categorical features and finally we
always need to provide where we need to
file write this file also optionally you
could provide names for each feature so
that your entry will train the model or
look at some analytic analysis of model
we will have names of each instead of
indexes all of them
and so in the cell I created this file
and write it to Amazon slash train dot
see the file and content of this file is
here we have tab separated file first
column is a index or of column second
column is a type of column in now the
set we have zero column is a label and
all other columns are features
categorical features so we have our file
like this in the next several cells
there are examples that some parameters
are optional for example we could skip
specifying future names and then this
file will have no names for features
secondly sometimes we have the set V is
not only categorical features Buzzbee is
busy America wants if we will not
specify those columns then in this
column description file it will be
interest like this we will be we will
read that column is numerical and not
categorical one okay so you could if you
work with ipython you could look at the
commutation and see much of this
function function could do okay after we
created this column description file we
could load the data to the memory from T
sphere or comma separated file and this
could be done just like this we need to
set the data from the data option
parameter to path for a file we need to
set a column description option to path
for a column description file that we
have created before and then kamusta
will kill every work for you and
download and create instance of pull off
the nature you will be able to use to
this cost to load to train models to
them and so on okay one more
I think the most efficient way to create
a pool class is to dilute it from disk
but in some applications you still want
to do it work in Python for example you
want to prepare this your data is for
example numpy and then train a basic
model or you want to apply model we
provided a special collector class
called feature data I don't know why but
my ipython don't doesn't show
documentation so I will not able to show
you its parameters what this course
requires dust or two main arguments
firstly you will need to provide an
umpire arabia's or categorical features
this numpy matrix with particular
features and secondly you will need to
provide and the by matrix B the
numerical features and if you use
features data class then you will then
Carlos will try to copy access the data
as efficiently as it could be done for
example we will not copy numerical
features to our internal format we will
use them just pointers from non PI RS
what this can't be done for data frames
and so and so so there will be overhead
son if he will use ponds and to work
with speeches data class and if you
notice which data cost we could
integrate incidence of our podcast so
just like here or in a Cell firstly we
created features data wrapper for numpy
matrix and then we provided 2's argument
for a data of our pool class constructor
and this class will be created more
efficiently than from pandas
oh I understand why there is no
documentation it was here so the
commutation for features later he needs
to specify numerical matrix we need to
specify categorical matrix and
optionally we could provide names for
features and with this class we will be
able to efficiently start the training
but usually you should use this class to
make projects and not to attend models
because most important thinker this
discuss was specially designed to allow
users to store the description of their
features and umpires and to apply Manos
fast but for training it's also useful
ok so we've created we've created three
three different pools they are a called
data we could train on each pool
instance caboose model and the third
source the same as formation here I
printed just that we've set out of the
same size but you could also check that
data in this causes are the same so this
was first tablet we need to do we need
to load that in memory after we will
need after we'll load the data in memory
you could start train melosa for the
rest of tutorial I was huge that we have
one train set and we have validation set
and here I just split it our all the set
is all data to train and that set with a
80% of a train and so we I have train
matrix and I happily - Maddox okay when
we deal with mutant car and when we
solve
if occasion problems we solve them by
optimization of some objective function
in boosting a different objective
function allows you to solve different
problems we have objective functions for
regression like mean square error or
mean absolute error we have special
objective functions of ranking tasks and
we have objective function for
classification
usually there are two main types of
objective that needs to be that I used
in classification tasks firstly its
algorithmic closer and and this
objective is used when we have zeros and
was once as a label secondly it's a
cross Intrepid track target this is
generalization of logarithmic loss to a
situation when we for each observation
we have not a label with zero on one
what we have probability that this
observation belongs to some class and to
to say and when you work your Cris can
boost you need to specify your loss
function dependent on problem you need
to solve for classification problems we
have and we have several different in
caboose have several classes that could
be used to train models firstly we have
think method if you have class boost and
this is most generic one usually you
don't need to use it it will not come at
you all functionality for example for
classification problem its most generic
one and you should to use sub classes we
have sub class caboose Crucifier this
sub class provides your special methods
to predict probabilities for classes to
estimate what class you need to predict
and also this class will automatically
specify for you LS function that should
be a nice focus if occasion by default
this class will use algorithm it was to
train your models but you could
optionally change this
was function through other and if you
will need to use course entropy if your
labels are probabilities that you could
just change change was function for
course entropy and everything will work
automatically let's train our first
model in the current cell I created the
basic instance of caboose classifier
Russ said 'keep are some cheaper
parameters in boosting we have to mine
steeper parameters it's the number of
iterations and it's doing great usually
we train a model on for several
alterations with some fixed grade and
look at test error on a holiday ssin set
and stop tank when our grid starts to
overheat well for first example I've
just added number of duration for five
angels running great to 0.1 it lasts for
example and after we created instance of
all class set key parameters B wants to
use they need to call this function
provide trained data set provide
evaluation set and maybe some and we
have some other parameters that will
simplify everything will you allow you
to look at progress to plate plots and
so on
I will later show them so this cell just
our first model if trained model we
could after we trained model we have is
featured function this function will
tell you that this instance of this cost
was featured on a some data set and we
have great params function that will set
what parameters we are used when you
change the model this he needed to
specify learning data set and the test
data set as instance of pool class it's
not very easy sometimes some for some
experiments you want just to pass data
frame
mantequilla smart list it is labels and
and you hope that everything will work
automatically because some other
libraries machine azam azam ocean i
believe this could work with such
interface and you could read any record
because of this booster could create
instances of pool cast automatically and
without explicit creation of them like
this we could pass to fit function just
matrix via speeches reactor of these
labels then we need to specify what
categorical features are and we could
specify evaluation set as a pair of
matrix with features and a vector with
values and I would will also learn
everything automatically but again this
should be good only on a small data sets
because the smaller sets our cat will be
small what when you need to do this with
very big data it is not a very good
solution and also it's not very flexible
one for some for different applications
for other objective functions like
ranking you will need you will need to
create instances of pootis because you
will not specify some more information
like weights of courses like how you
should group the data to make rank and
so on and it can be easily done in
syntax like this ok so we treated first
model now we physical model without any
information when you train a model you
want to look at progress how your ink is
going going on how many time we will
need to learn models what is error on
validation set which is error on
learning set and so on should be stopped
our link and join most we could report
you information about focus in several
different ways
firstly we could write everything in
standard output
here is an example we have optional
organ level you could set it to boss and
after this that boost will print your
information about training of
thematically they both will create view
on each iteration that most will write
you several different columns firstly it
will write you error on learning set
this is a value of objective function
that almost optimize secondly and most
will write your error error on a
relation said this is a value of
objective function on test set and the
next column is a best value it's when we
train rejected again we exaggerate
algorithm are and for different
arbitration we have different objectives
this comb is a example of is a number of
trees that will provide you the best
quality into for your validation data
set so it's number of iteration that you
should should drink more after training
so that you have the best results and
then we have column with time that we
spent during the call model and finally
we have estimated time that can boot
will need to finish the training when we
deal with Eugene booting and we and we
deal with decision trees duration time
is almost constant so we could estimate
mean time very efficiently and
especially this is true for canvas
because in compost we have special type
of trees and they usually change in
constant time some other library stacks
IBM will need good train I'd only known
in non constant time significant on
constant ok after the thing will be done
almost will print a value of objective
function on the best duration just like
this and the this iteration and by
default car both will shrink your model
for this best iteration so that your
quality is
as best as it could be okay for more
advanced users we have other logic
levels so if someone wants to look at
the decision tree that found on each
iteration they could create a login
level you know for and look at more
information which I will not stop on
this and details key so the first way to
track your progress is to look at where
each locks to look at text information
text information is not very useful we
could do create images of what plots for
our learning error for our test error
and this is more this more useful it's
much easier to look on approach then to
look at some text and in Cal boost we
have in turn we could create
visualization just in Jupiter notebook
so and this is this this could be done
very easily
we just need to specify port option to
true and then caboose to create ports
like this lets me zoom this so it
started training now cat booster will
will will dynamically update plot during
training
we'll watch your error on a learning set
we will quote your error
it said curve this one that was down we
will put you on a test set it's a solid
curve and also we will print time that
you will need to spend to the remaining
time it will be I think here and the
time that we've already learnt our model
it will be here and there is a dot it's
a best iteration on a validation set
okay one more thing this is our internal
port it's to use our code to make this
this visualization and both could also
create
what's in a tensor board format you
could create and you could look at
what's in tender world but I don't have
this in tutorial you could you look at
our documentation and see how it could
be done okay now today we talk about
notifications when we talk about
classification you don't want to look at
objective function that we optimizing we
want to look at some more meaningful
metric like accuracy like a we see a
metric like recall or precision or we
want to look at F measure this matrix
are more Despres you could interpret
taste this metric and this metric is
more useful for users and when we train
boost models we also want to be able to
shrink our model based on metric like
accuracy not on objective function we
want to make plots of this metric and
can boost provided you know several ways
to achieve this firstly we have option
eval metric this option is a main metric
that can boost should care about firstly
this metric will be used to make clothes
in our widget let me run this so we will
taught you this metric and show
everything about this metric or NATO
stop
objective function will be also printed
but in another tab secondly this metric
is a magnetics and we will use this
metric to shrink our model now we will
not use objective function we will use
this simulation metric for full full
list of all metrics that we could
complete during training look at
documentation which we could use but
almost any metric that you will need I
think is already implemented if it's not
you could create an issue and we will do
this
okay now the second thing that we have
one more one more thing this I've told
before that cannot mistake you model we
have also if you don't want to shrink
your model because you have different
metrics and you want to compute several
metrics and then decide decide what
amount of fleece he wants to use based
on different metrics then we have option
use best model you should set it to
false and can boost will not shrink the
model and here you can see that the best
iteration was 23 but we doesn't stream
the model and our model is all 50
iterations ok now this was about one
imported metric and but sometimes we
want we have one budget matrix like
objective function on like accuracy and
we have several other metrics that we
want to look at for example we could
want to look at AUC and accuracy and at
F measure and kal booth could track this
matrix automatically generates a link
and could use several metrics not just
one for this we have option custom was
option here is an example we specify a
path to call most list of metrics that
caboose should compute run again fit
function now we will plot you a
variation metric this is very close
because I doesn't change it and we will
load create tabs for this custom metrics
and we will plot you a geometric and
accuracy so you could look at what and
again decide where you need to shrink
the model okay now let's look at a close
boy you see metric you can see that here
you don't have a dotted curve this is
the curve for our learning data set why
because you see metric and some other
metrics are very expensive to compute
when you have very big learn data set
and you compute a symmetric and
especially if this that will have just
several columns then you will spend
almost all time a picture yet extent of
doing but in reality you care about only
error on validation set so you don't
need to compute a metric on the on set
and you don't want to spend time capital
and because of this by default we don't
compute some metrics on learning set if
you will need to this you will need to
explicitly say it say to card boast that
you should compute metrics and for this
we have hints we have several different
hits booster and the marker that he
really needs to use is he hint that you
should not skip train by default we skip
train equal to true for every symmetric
we could change it just like this and
boost will create huge netted curve this
is error on a training set and one more
useful thinker if you want to compute a
be symmetric and what is to care about
performance we have an option metric
period and we can't compute matrix for
you not on each iteration but with some
interval so here is an example I've just
computed metric not on each iteration
but with some with some period okay
let's look on next year's poor thing
that caboose has compared with the
follows we could make a plot so look at
what and decide what model is better
based on learning curve on a test set
and caboose provides you an easy way to
achieve this task we could create
compare
model straining attained with different
parameters we could create plots just
like this but automatically for from
looks that Cal busca generates gr-18
when you start train cough can boost we
create so called strain indirect area by
default it's got boost and we store
every summation about doing in this
directory for example they will be filed
that will allow you to create returns
are both locks they will be a file that
contains information about learning care
about test error and also the railway
file file that contains every
information about visualization if and
if we'll create four different training
tasks different directories then we will
be able to letter compare a different
model so here I want I will train two
models provide training directory for
different arguments so they will be
changing names like this training
director names like this I will train
two models and after I will train these
models we have metric visualizer class
this metric is eliezer class need a list
of directories where can boost stores
box and it will automatically get the
data that it needs to create quotes and
visualize everything so now we have two
different conversed models with
different green curves and we could look
at them and decide what model is better
and how we could and need to adjust
parameters okay now
let's go to the next function that we
have now when we deal with boostin kavya
usually train model until we start
overfitting on a new data set we don't
we don't know how many iterations we
should set and because of this usually
it's everyone said numbered Federation
everyone it maybe not everyone but many
people will set number of iterations for
some big amount train a model for this
number of iteration then look at curve
and stream the model or like almost it
will be synced automatically but you
will spend computation power for several
durations to after we are worth it and
this lamb of duration could be pretty
big to deal with this problem and boost
provides you another feature detector we
have several different types over
kitchen detectors some of them are
designed to work well we also know with
functions with local minerals like once
in Arendal but for tasks like
classification it's usually you usually
could use a very simple or a fitting
detector it's it's written refutation
detector that will stop train after we
the best iteration will be the gap with
best iteration and current iteration
will be bigger than some number of
iterations and this efficient data could
be used just like here in a cell we said
early stepping grounds I go to some
number and train our model Vanka must be
able train model here the best duration
is 19 it will train for 20 more
iteration check that airing error is not
yes almost everyone every parameters
because we tried to make it simple to
users to change from user busto catalyst
so
almost any parameter will have a synonym
in conduced yes we basically we have a
special function that will remove
parameters we have our own names for all
parameters we new parameters we'll try
to name just like a booster so it could
be very easy to speech thank you for
good question
I forget about to talk about this okay
so we've could train model and see that
we've stopped our model in our
documentation could find it emerged
about other type of indicator it's
slightly harder to use what is in some
applications provide you a better
quality okay now we will asymmetric this
well this metric is is my metric so if
you will set this metric and we will use
our fitting detector then Cal boast will
use the relation metric to think a model
so it's just so you won't be surprised
if you want to use simulation metric
then it will be used almost everywhere
now the next thing after you train you
know of to you train just one model you
want to maybe you want to make some
cross-validation to estimate quality of
your algorithm for this we have we've
completed a cross relation function that
will do cross-validation automatically
we just need to create parameters that
we want to use for training now we need
to specify explicit objective function
that will be optimized in crucification
I again say that it algorithmic laws and
we have function C V in package can
boast that except params it's a
dictionary with parameters that we want
to use in training it
takes influence of pool class that we've
created several times again today and
parameters for cross-pollination first
its number of faults in this example
it's 5 then in a parameter inverted this
tells how we should do cross planation
when we do in crystallization it could
be split the data for 5 volts use and we
could use four volts for training set
and one for test set or we could do
otherwise we could use one for training
set and four for test set and this does
draw this then we have two parameters
that tells can boost how to create make
Raziel Edition should be shocked of the
data before we all split for defaults
and seed a random seed for repair to
make it reproducible and applaud
function that will watch everything just
as before
here I've run CB now we created a
slightly different what we will compute
standard deviation based on several
models that we launched almost billion
models iteratively all five ones for
each fault so we could use it in after
stop and and in other personality and
yeah we have this box we could turn it
off
and look at errors four inch model on a
relation set and caboose will return you
a lot of data cream this data frame will
be a errors learn and test errors for
all metrics they mean and they a
standard deviation okay and it could be
used to walk access for example the best
iteration
based on cross-validation estimation now
one more useful thing in our cross
validation function we could do not only
a classical cross validation you could
do testified cross cross validation when
we have invalid data sets it sometimes
wants to ensure that proportion of zeros
and ones will be equal to proportion in
all the
set in each vault and to ensure this we
could split to split data with zero
classes and data vias classes one
classes two folds independently and then
and then ensure that proportion is one
thing that we need and for this we have
certified a coach a true option keep a
bit slow today so let's go to the next I
think that should be discussed when we
train crucification model we obtain
model that reports YouTube ability based
on this capability you need to to decide
which threshold you should use to select
to decide is this zero class or it's one
class and this default almost always
depends on problem that my knowledge we
could use standard approach to say that
area think there is great the ability
for which is greater than 0.5 should be
class 1 and although they should because
0 but for many problems it's not
desirable here I just trained model so
the most we could help you with this
task you could create arrow Chico
automatically we could plot false
positive rate we see threshold curve
false negative rate we see threshold
curve and select threshold based on
false positive rate or true positive
rate automatically here is an example
firstly let's create arrow C curve for
this we have a function in our tools
it's get error she curve we need to
specify model we need to specify data
and everything will be done
automatically for you here in a cell
example we've created instance of ball
toss
created curve and approached it to me is
what not sleep so we have curfew could
look at it and make some decisions now
like now if you watch to look at fast
positively rate curve or fights negative
rate curve we also could create them
they could look at the commutation and
see that we could create it based on
model and data as in previous example
all we could provide results from get
our C curve function and here in example
of how to create create a plot and if
you just want to set for five positive
rate for example for some specific value
we have a select result function that
will create a decision based on false
positive rate and I'll snap it plate
okay now the next thing assuming we'd
train a model on a very big data set you
have some program and you have machine
that you have access for example for
just 30 minutes
Andy wants to train more model then stop
training and continue training in some
other day and so on for this people we
have managed to create snapshots we
could write our earlier in progress in a
file and then we could download our
learning progress fall over this file
and continue learning so this we need to
say it
save some short option to true select a
file where snapshot will be stored and
interval with which we will write
everything and boot will continue
learning I forgot to delete my snapshot
so I've already trained all 20
iterations and can boost doesn't do
anything much I could set number of
iterations for a bigger number or and
boost will continue training I had
had model these 20 iterations on my disk
cuz both double-digit and continually
rank from 20 integration to two hundred
iterations to until three hundred
situations okay now after we'll train
model we will need to make predictions
to make prediction prediction it's
called boost is very easy because if
occasion we have true
main functions firstly its predict probe
of honkin it just access instance of
pool class maybe without labels and
returns you a matrix with two columns
first column is a probability of class 0
and second column is probability across
one if you will solve much
classification problem there will be
several different columns with
probability for each class secondly we
have function predict this function will
return you number at a label of class
that should be chosen okay and finally
our pijit function have option
prediction type if we if you know the
math behind to the cell then you don't
know that Booton Prince boosting our
boosting the serial output not
probabilities but some value you will
apply sigmoid function for this value
and obtain probability and so both would
connect this row for model value or
results this could be used for example
to to make some bacon on several models
and so on because it's sometimes non
desirable to your keys probabilities and
we could and here honest in a Cell I
just compared that after I will apply my
sigmoid I will obtain this column anyone
could check that they are just the same
numbers and not because here just first
three and last three much they are echo
okay and now what you think about
features data I thought I said before
that we have which is data across that
allows to make prediction and to allow
us to make predictions past and it's
especially true for all the medical
pitches
this example is for categorical bonds
but the idea will be the same when we
will use this in numerical features you
could create a two part equal pass the
data for predict proper function with a
features data class is instance of
features data class and almost-- will
compute the same predictions but it will
be a significant factor than if you will
provide just compiled matrix opens data
frame okay now we have one more useful
think Lea's prediction we could create
predictions on some iteration you could
come we have an example there are
several different trees and we could
compute predictions for example of size
1 for example of size 2 and so on even
what even moment could compute
predictions static from in sample of
size 2 then going with some step
computes and predictions for one sample
of size 4 6 and so on and return you in
iterate through these predictions so you
could implement your some custom metric
function create you applaud portfolio
metric and create learning curve for
this metric if for this metric is not
implemented by can boost over idea and
here is an example how we could achieve
this we call stage Bridget proper
function pass the data pass the first
tree we want to use
lastly we want to use and period with
which the booth will compute everything
and almost will return here in iterator
that will make predictions for in
several size 2 4 and 6 k1 small small
small example that could also be used
not to project manager classification
problem but for multi classification
problems this is very simple we just
need to change your loss function from
logarithmic loss to multi class and a
multicast is a generalization of that
across for multi classification
watch when you deal with muta
crucification there are other ways to
perform it for example you could train
one where's Otis afire and caboose also
could do this by changing loss function
to which across one versus all now after
will train the model they want you to
compute metric firstly you could use
page Bridget proper function to copy to
custom metrics what we have a big number
of metrics that we've already
implemented and Cal both good caboose
could compute them for you automatically
all right they're in this cell I just
train one more model which I will use to
create matrix to create matrix to
compute matrix for our example we have
evolve matrix function this function
again access instance of pull class it
requires to provide metrics that tree
should be computed and parameters that
you already seen in stage project
function it's the first iteration that
should be used last iteration that
should be used and step with which
matrix will be computed for example if
you want to compute them faster there
and you don't need precise results on
each iteration and if you set port
function to true then a boost will
create plots just like once you've seen
during training so here is the result
and yesterday's Alchemist will return
you and dictionary this dictum and we'll
map metric name to array with scores on
each iteration and here you can see
result okay finally when you train your
model you want to save each other disk
to share with someone or to use it in a
production service and so on
to save the model we know we just needs
to call save model function and specify
file in calmest we have special format
this format is optimized for
education and we also ensure that we
will be able to you to apply your models
in our if it's can boost in future
versions so we have record capability
you could train model today and then we
will be able to apply this model all I
think until our library will be used by
nobody and I hope it will be not very
soon and now to to load this model we
just need to create instance of canvas
class called load model function and
provide path for this model and Jeckle
mostly load it and we will be able to
apply it also we could write our model
in other formats this formats optimized
for us tasks for example we have this
old format that will present our model
in useful in human that human could look
at and heard for example on Alice they
spoiled Desai look at decision trees and
make some and get some information from
this also we have you could export
formats to core mal format and our
models could be applied efficiently on
Apple devices and we have some other
formats you could look at documentation
what this basically will be applied in
applier in dust c++ which is not very
efficient but it's just a quote or as
far as I remember it's a Python
applier that written just in Python code
okay now after you will train your model
you want to look at your future so to
look
what features are imported how they how
they are potent and how each feature
influence predictions of your model and
for this we have
support for Fiji importance method
methods let's trade again train model
firstly we have feature importance is
for that Capuchin Julian training cadet
Emile if you're a basic idea of how a
project feature for this model is this
feature importance could be gated just
like this we could call great switch
importance with option play fitra a
coach otro at this will be and we will
get values for each feature from our
information contained training and this
feature buttons this you'll give you
just one number we could sort each
feature by sort reaches by this number
and decide and look at this list and
beside watch watch features I'm what and
what are not and how they are important
what today the most useful I think the
most useful thing for decision trees to
compute the feature importances is strap
various this is technique that was
proposed on nibs in the pale in in
previous nibsy everyone who sees shape
values the first time I suggest to look
at the github wait look at their paper
they explain how they do in prediction
why they doing this predictions in
optimal way so they have a good
motivation to make these predictions to
use for the algorithm are very good area
and in calmest we've implemented
integration these are packaged that
authors of shop where shared values
provides so how to compute values for
can boost just import their package
shape package create explainer and it's
created just like this we need to
provide a model and finally we compute
shape values for instance of our pool
clause
and as a result you will have chef alias
that could be used in in a visualization
functionality provided by a package you
could look at what's like this this
plots will describe you how important
each feature is for a single observation
Sopranos is a which importance based on
observation they report your influence
of the reporter in the influence of each
feature for just single observation and
here the big box is the budget
projection the more influence this
feature has on these observations and
color is how each object prediction it
will add some positive number for a
prediction or some negative 1 enter the
predictions could be computed for
different observations and they could be
summarized they could be summarized in
plots like this but for categorical
feature it's not very useful plot and
I'm and what's the spot contains the
spot will computer will show you a
histogram for shop values for each
feature and use a color when we deal
with numerical features so we could
compare values of this feature and the
low-low for lower values we will use a
blue color and four big ones we will use
red color so we could use for this from
the spots we could we'll be able to
estimator if we have some monotonic
someone and tonic relation with the
speech if for example we'll make a
feature lower then prediction will be
higher but today we have example with
only categorical predictors
so this color is not very useful and
again from for more detail the
description I asked you to look at look
at the documentation because I just
don't have time we could create
if you want to just computer how
important each feature is summarized
based on each data set we could create a
summary quad just like this and here we
will have worse with reported this for
each feature okay I think I should skip
this two sections and we will we could I
could ask way I could answer some
questions difference to this ones yes
for this one's okay so featuring chef
Bayless is a feature buttons based just
on one sample and this switch importance
has a good motivation to access
importance of feature for one sample
they could be generalized they could be
this various could be greased it through
all that set computer mean value for
example and be used as importance or
feature of entire data set but we have
more or all the techniques that could be
computed for each data set and they just
just you can take the computed during
training so this one's are features
computed during training and this is
very simple technique where it's that
you could find in classical statistics
and it should provide similar results
that we will see by summarizing shape
various first implanted this and then
there was a package with shape and via
edge support for sharp errors like this
just using suppose because I'm author or
GP regression and most if I will need
this is at risk from it is a boost I
will just write though
I I know I could I know how to make very
efficient decision trees and because of
this if I will need some quality
furniture boost it's much easier for me
to implement this I could compare can
boost music use a boost and then I
decide that I need this feature from a
boost and I should implement it because
basically I work with very big datasets
and I can't use the boost office but in
some times on some competitions the
boost could provide some pathetic
quality especially for people who know
the Boost well and know how to tune the
parameters and it can boost we have
special type addition trees they have
some limitations and sometimes they
could be a slightly worse you can't use
the same parameters there is support
this is a problem we have different type
of decision trees because of this we
sometimes we very often it begins simple
like you could train 200 extra boost
durations and you need 504 Cal boost and
also you can't reuse the same learning
rate for example because it just doesn't
comparable the they mean similar things
like how weak you example should be how
deep your twist should be but they are
not comparable in terms of quality we
will obtain other different models you
should always some create learning
course and decide based on them
[Music]
so no more questions okay then I think
we could finish
[Applause]